-Nous allons accueillir
cette ravissante Vanessa.
Regarde comme elle est jolie.
Fais une grosse bise à Philippe.
Et vous l'applaudissez très fort.
On aurait dit que j'avais
préparé le micro pour toi.
Quel âge tu as, Vanessa ?
-7 ans.
-Tu es Française ?
-Oui.
-Où habites-tu ?
-Villiers-sur-Marne.
-Tu n'es pas venue de très loin ?
-Non.
-Tu es venue en famille
ou toute seule ?
-En famille.
-Tu nous la présente ?
-Ma maman, mon papa
et mon parrain.
-Où il est ton papa ?
-Là.
-C'est le moustachu ?
-Oui.
-Ca pique ses moustaches ?
-Non.
-Les papas ont toujours
des moustaches qui ne piquent pas.
Comment elle s'appelle ta maman ?
-Corinne.
-Bonjour, Corinne.
Ils travaillent tous les deux ?
-Ma mère elle travaille.
-Tu as des frères et des soeurs ?
-Non, je suis
une petite fille unique.
-T'aimerais avoir
des frères et des soeurs ?
-Oui.
-Combien tu en voudrais ?
-Une seule.
-Voilà, vous voyez
ce qui vous reste à faire !
Vous remplirez un bon de commande !
Dis donc, j'ai l'impression
que tu fais un peu de danse.
Tu fais un peu de danse ?
-Oui.
-De la danse classique ?
-Rythmique.
-Fais-moi voir.
Fais-moi voir comment
on fait la danse rythmique.
Comme ça ?
C'est pas comme ça ?
Tu fais de la danse rythmique
et tu ne veux pas me montrer ?
-Non.
-Tu veux chanter, quand même ?
-Oui.
-Que vas-tu chanter ?
-"Emilie Jolie et le grand oiseau".
-Emilie Jolie...
C'était celle que j'attendais,
je la chante tout le temps.
Vas-y.
[Intro musicale.]
[...]
-"Je m'appelle Emilie Jolie.
"Je m'appelle Emilie Jolie.
"Je voudrais partir avec vous,
"tout au bout du ciel,
"sur vos ailes,
et je voudrais vivre avec vous,
"ma vie.
"Tu t'appelles Emilie Jolie.
"Tu voudrais
"partir avec nous,
"tout au bout du ciel,
"sur nos ailes,
"et tu voudrais vivre avec nous,
"ta vie.
"Oui, c'est ça vous m'avez compris,
"alors dites-moi oui.
"Tu t'appelles Emilie Jolie.
"Tu rêves de voler la nuit,
"partir rejoindre le soleil
"et même la lune
"sur nos plumes,
"et tu voudrais vivre avec nous,
"ta vie.
"Oui, c'est ça vous m'avez compris,
"alors, dites-moi oui.
"Mais y a tant de choses
à voir avant,
"de partir pour le firmament.
"Y a tant de pages à tourner.
"Ta vie ne fais que commencer.
"Y a tant de choses
à voir avant,
"de partir pour le firmament.
"Y a tant de jours et tant de nuits.
"Tu es au début de ta vie."
-Formidable !
Vraiment touchant.
Tu sais... Viens voir.
Tu sais ce que me disais
l'auteur de cette chanson ?
Que tu chantes très juste.
Tu fais de la musique ?
-Oui, du piano.
-Ah, c'est pour ça !
On l'applaudit très fort
et on lui donne une note.
Attention, Philippe,
tu es très attentif.
Cédric,
tu choisis ce que tu veux.
Voilà.
10. Très bien, Cédric.
10, 10, 9, 10 et 8.
Reposez vos plaquettes.
Notre avant dernier candidat,
un ravissant petit garçon,
David.